Ще раз добрий день ми не просто Багато
ваших пропозицій запитань вони Практично
всі співпадають тому як будемо працювати
по запитанням чи я спробую відразу
прокоментувати
прокоментуй
і саме головне потім віддам вам
оригінали всіх документів і накази все
для кожного якщо в когось буде бажання
будь ласка
Ну давайте Я спочатку тоді тому що
просто більше На всіх не вистачить ми
поробимо ще куди
Шановні колеги ми сьогодні з вами
зібрались по доволі дивовижному приладу
спростовувати те чого ніколи не було
Хіба що можемо обговорити
новоязе якісь новий політичний коли
задумки пропонують розстрілювати за
нереалізований проекти карати і таке
інше На мою думку це дивовижна ситуація
яку
крайні радикали
намагаються імплементувати в наше життя
наміри середньовічної інквізиції можуть
збліднути порівняно з фразеологією
логікою деяких наших сучасників А тепер
по суті коротка довідка ти пови
навчальні плани документи який на
виконання статті 15 Закону України Про
загальну середню освіту розробляється
Міністерство освіти на основі базового
навчального плану та містить
конкретизацію розподілу навчальних годин
між навчальними предметами
базовий навчальний план є складовою
державної стандарту розподіляє навчальні
години між освітніми галузями та
затверджується Кабінетом Міністрів
на інформацію вигадану окремими
політиками і окремими засобами масової
інформації можу сказати ніхто ніколи не
збирався інтегрувати і об'єднувати курси
історії України і всесвітньої історії
більше двох місяців працює робоча група
яка готує
програму окремо історії України окремо
всесвітня історія очолює керівник
відділу в національній академії
педагогічних наук професор доктор наук
Пометун Вона знаходиться зараз у
відрядженні але робоча група підготувала
обурене спростування яке вони офіційно
дали для сайту Міністерства Олена
Іванівна Пометун коли повернеться також
дасть вам всі необхідні коментарі але в
складі цієї робочої групи півтора
десятків фахівців які плідно продовжу
ють працювати над новим навчальним
планом історії України це перше друге
спеціально для політиків дебілів з 98-го
року жодна година в жодному класі на
викладання історії України не
зменшувалась і не змінювалась
ще раз повторюю для брехунів пройти
свідків і демагогів жодна година
порівняно з 98-м роком на викладання
історії України не змінювалась не
передбачається це змінювати і в
навчальних планах згідно нового
стандарту
наступне
кількість годин відведених на вивчення
української літератури в 5-8 класі була
є і залишається на тому ж рівні що діє
сьогодні
предмету історії України теж нічого не
загрожує все інше Це вигадана хвора уява
моїх політичних опонентів
ніяких скорочень навчальних годин
відведених на вивчення як історій
України так і всесвітньої історії не
відбувається і не передбачається
все навчальне навантаження
передбачається виключно в межах
державних санітарних норм і в межах
державного бюджету тому що зайву
кількість годин важко
сконструювати якщо немає відповідних
фінансових ресурсів
ще одне хотів би сказати розроблено три
варіанти типового навчального плану один
варіант передбачає
зменшити на півгодини на тиждень
деякі предмети щоб знайти дві години на
другу іноземну мову тому що в Європі до
якої Я вірю що ми щиро прагнемо
майже 90% всіх школярів європейських
країн вивчають дві іноземні мови це
якість освіти це мобільність в світі це
спілкування
згідно нового стандарту ми дійсно хотіли
б і будемо це робити вести починаючи з 5
класу другу іноземну мову а також хотіли
б збільшити
збільшити кількість годин на
природничі і математичній дисципліні
стосовно
одного штатного фахівця обріховича який
себе позиціонує як експерт
з освітніх питань які розпочав цю
колотнечу ми підготували спростування до
газети яка все це поширила ну хочу
сказати що
потреба збільшення математики і
інформатики це об'єктивна причина яка
визначає якість освіти тому що наша
космічна держава не може змиритися з тим
що по використанню
інформаційно-комунікаційних
технологій ми посідаємо сумно
непрестижне 97 місце в світі і цей так
званий експерт який керував впродовж
багатьох років освіти і підготовкою
програм він весь час говорив про те що
необхідно збільшити цикли математичних
дисциплін Чому цього не зробив чому не
заклав мабуть калькулював свої гонорари
за підручники тому що за весь час
перебування на посаді будь-кого з
заступників міністрів цей так званий
експерт
настільки був етичним Що кожного року за
кошти державного бюджету друкував
підручники по державному замовленню
більше ніхто А ні в каденцію ніколаєнка
А ні в каденцію кремня А ні в каденцію
Вакарчука Ані в каденцію Табачника
заступників міністра і з міністром тим
більше не друкував свої підручники за
державні кошти
далі можна переходити багато так би
мовити розказувати про вже такі
суто-педагогічні суто-педагогічні речі я
думаю що вони менше цікаві тепер
пройдуся по вашим запитанням так по
Інтеру я сказав і по історії по
літературі